take a look at this chart this is from
the New York Post when Biden takes
office inflation skyrockets this isn't
the only chart it's just the one I just
quickly Google searched there's one that
is is more
um
it's more granular gets down into the
days and I remember seeing this and it
talks about wages and inflation the
moment Joe Biden is elected he signs a
bunch of executive orders and we see
inflation go straight up and wages go
straight down and I've had people say oh
well the reason that Spike happens and
nothing to do with Biden it's because of
the debt spending in Coven and I'm like
no no no you can't say that and then see
the change happen literally right after
the signing of like 30 executive orders
something he did right when he got an
office caused this flip to happen yep or
unless you're arguing some Grand
conspiracy where Trump set some
executive orders to expire I don't think
anyone can believe that credibly because
again I don't think that there's anyone
even on the conservative side that was
actually really working with Trump to
help him I think they did everything
they could to subvert him including the
FED including you know I I don't think
he'd pretend that those guys were
working I think you know in the midst of
a pandemic yeah you had to do some
spending to keep businesses open that's
fine but they want to keep that going in
perpetuity uh you know it it's it it
just doesn't work the math doesn't
you're gonna have to pay the piper
sometime
I think I actually may have found real
clear politics this is from Real Clear
Politics take a look at this
so right when Joe Biden gets inaugurated
you can see wages drop way down and
inflation spikes it's incredible yeah
Biden Administration right when he comes
in
crashes yeah you know and that's the sad
thing I mean you know bringing those
jobs back to America you know I I I went
to boarding school but I went to
boarding school in like sort of you know
central Pennsylvania sort of old sort of
industrial Town one of those towns that
you know time forgot and again growing
up it was the home of Firestone Tires
and like Mrs Smith's pies and stuff like
that you just see these you know
dilapidated buildings and stuff like
that and it's just like man these were
once like great like thriving areas that
are just run down and it's like bringing
those jobs back bringing back American
manufacturing bringing back car
manufacturing to Detroit like it was
happening like it's not rocket science
like you can do it if you even care a
little bit if you can break away from
the billionaires if you can you can
actually do this still in America and
then to just to watch that reversal
to what degree is it an intentional
is it is it a controlled demolition
right how could it not be man like you
know what I mean like again all Joe
Biden had to do was nothing
you know let the ship sail continue it
out you know they can't you know they
they even say you know they want it well
we and then a year later they're like
where we're gonna bring back maybe
Trump's policy on the border because
well yeah because it was always working
you had to do something different right
the withdrawal of Afghanistan a true
disgrace you know you you couldn't just
leave it alone the way they had it you
had to change it so you could have the
headline of you did it faster so instead
of doing it during the winter when
they're hiding in caves you do it during
the fighting season when they can come
and take over Kabul in 12 days but they
never they couldn't see it coming I'm
like I'm not a military expert but let's
just assume I know jack about
Afghanistan like oh I saw that coming
it's on purpose you know like they saw
it coming but they needed the sound bite
knowing that there was no consequence
because the media big Tech would make
sure the story was like Joe Biden did
this he's a great hero he he had to mess
it up he couldn't leave it alone they
needed to make it their own and they
knew that if they made it their own even
if it's a disaster they got full
coverage by the media of how one
wonderful and great he is just like
those same people are telling you that
he created more jobs than any president
in history
I think the American people believe it
because I feel like a lot of Americans
remember what happened in Afghanistan
and they will not be able to forget it I
I you know again I think we're chipping
away slowly you know I think it's why
they're going to do what they can to
prevent the inevitable you know from
happening because you know when it gets
really bad when you see that 08 kind of
Crash you know like they changed the
definition of recession a year ago like
what is a recession like if it was under
Trump you know if you met this level of
not GDP growth for this amount of time
at any other point in time it's history
they go well that's just the way we've
kind of done it but it it's it's not
really like etched in stone but I was
like but you mean you're saying that now
because we've hit that level that puts
us in a quote-unquote recession but if
it was Trump like you wouldn't be
changing the definition to like pretend
like we're not in a recession even
though every metric we've used
historically forever has been met to say
we are there they would make the rules
more strict if it was
it's technically a recession it really
is much worse than growth was lower than
five percent this year so really it's a
recession I do love when Obama was like
what do you say there's no magic wand
you can't get four percent growth
Abracadabra
but it is but again it didn't take it
didn't take that much and again this is
with
even a lot of the people on our own side
working against us and I mean that's
sort of the miracle of the Trump
residency is like he actually knocked
some pretty serious wins despite the
Republicans working I mean Paul Ryan and
the things that they were I don't want
to do that like if we build a wall like
we may upset a couple people like who
hate us like and put us in the gulags
like I can't have that I'm like really
like do you think there are people like
that like if your dad wins next year are
there similar people who you would
advise him to be careful of who might
work against him oh I think 100 I think
he knows who probably most of those
people are yeah you know listen I'd say
you know the vast majority of of the
United States Senate uh you know there's
a couple great guys in there but you
know a tiny handful uh I think you know
the honestly it'd be much easier to name
people who aren't on the list than who
are interesting right I mean no but like
if we're going to be real I think
there's a couple great people in
Congress you know meaning the house uh
but again that's a small part of that
machine right the unelected bureaucrats
I manage
thing and I'm not sure I can name one
that isn't you know but no they did that
they inter you know Obama did that very
well they entrench a bunch of people
that are career and you try to change
the job role that you know that's not
appointed by the president so you can't
touch them their life they could be the
most incompetent people in the world but
they got ten years so they can stay
there like it makes it really difficult
to clean house it's the least Merit you
know there's no meritocracy in
Washington DC if you can get in those
positions uh you know you're there for
life I mean if you married at anything
you wouldn't be in DC of course yeah
exactly yeah you know if you're doing
five in the market and I think that's
the other part of the attack on Trump
which is like you know we don't really
want someone from out of the system ever
doing this again like you know that
system works really well for us and
we'll keep you know we we want to make
part of it's the statement of hey if
you're another successful guy who's done
this in the real world and you want to
get into politics and like you know
imagine what they try to do to you know
elon's not born in America so we can't
do it but if it was someone like that
that wanted to run for president yeah
I've done what I've you know I put
people on Mars and you know yada yada
yada maybe I'll do this imagine the
Revolt they don't want that that's a
threat to the system that they've
created that has been very beneficial to
them but no one else and that's why it's
so important they don't get away with
what they did to Trump with the FBI
attempting to unseen but this this means
because that will send the example to
the American people that they will beat
you if you try to stand up against I I I
don't think firing these people is
enough no I I I agree with you I just
don't listen
I have my opinions I have what I'd like
to have happen yeah uh Which is far more
grave than what would ever happen you
know the problem is you actually still
have to play Within the realm of reality
right yeah and you know I don't it
doesn't mean I'm compromising my
position my position may be X but I just
know it ain't happening nothing's gonna
happen no I want to keep pushing I want
to make sure we get people who elected
who can actually try to do that I'm
gonna do whatever I can to make that
happen but like you know sometimes we
get caught up on this is what I want and
if we don't do that I got 99 of what I
want and it's like business you don't
get it you don't yeah you never get 100
of what you want Republicans do that
poorly we we take our toys home and we
cry having like 99 of what we wanted
rather than taking the win and like
we'll work on the one percent starting
in five minutes yeah you know the
Democrats get 51 and they're starting on
the next one the next day they take the
win move on they take the win they move
on they take the win move on and it's a
death by a Thousand Cuts they get where
they want we don't do that well we don't
play that game well and you know and I
understand it's a lot of it's because
we're principled but I think a big part
of print you know my principle is
actually getting where I want to be
realistically and I don't want to blow
important wins because I didn't get a
hundred percent of what I wanted in that
and you know people oh you're a sellout
I'm like no I just this is how we
actually get some win instead of zero
wins whatsoever which is what we're
really good at getting I I don't know if
you would know but I'm curious your
thoughts on a potential vice
presidential pick for I think I think
it's too early right now
um so I I there hasn't been much
listen you know there I'd want someone
in there I just tasked a clean clean
house in certain things right
there's a couple guys out there that
could do that maybe specifically
um yeah well listen I'm not gonna go
because I know what the media will then
and Donald Trump Jr's undercutting his
father and he's announcing the game like
but
you're getting warmer you know I don't
know you know maybe we put Tim pool in
charge of doj just cleaning it like lock
him up Tim no but I think I think you
get some people I got it I got people
like Trump also who don't care anymore
the people some of the people who've
been wronged yeah okay the people who
they tried to break who they tried to
bankrupt and probably did in many cases
like you know I'm not saying all you
know because there's some that again you
gotta but like they're some of those
people that now understand that their
life meant nothing to these people and
when that happens to you you know maybe
like it happened to me like okay you
know what like I don't want to curse but
you know Fu and we're gonna like we
don't care and I think again that's the
most important that you know as much of
a just total reset not again that that
word will be used against me oh my God
conspiracy you're not allowed
to say start from scratch and eliminate
as much of that bureaucracy as possible
have people willing to be like you know
this guy's the North Korea he was an
expert he led the North Korea policy for
four years I was like what'd you do
well Trump's doing it all wrong but why
well hold on maybe because you've LED it
for 40 years but you've accomplished
nothing in four years like but you don't
what you got to do is you got to sit
them down and say what would you say you
do here yeah
it'll feel like yeah like office space
all over again I want to say you know uh
I despise politics I would never want to
be involved people jokingly say like
maybe you know why don't you run why
don't more people run if you're so
pissed off and I'm like I just want to
go anywhere near it I can't believe
people want to I told Carrie like I
can't believe you want to keep running
she's talking about the Senate but if uh
Donald Trump said look you complain so
much about these people we'll put you in
charge of all the indictments it's yours
now I built yes yes what is
conspiracy theorists who have been far
more right who have been far more
correct than uh all of our Elite and
educated media just let them you know
give them each a task and just be like
have at it I mean frankly informed in
conspiracy theorists are a redundancy
these days you know the conspiracy
theorists are they're bad like a
thousand is for us I'm concerned
absolutely even Elon Muskie said
recently in an interview he was like
well a lot of them turned out to be
right and the guy's like which ones and
he goes the hunter Biden laptop and then
the interviewer goes okay well that was
true yeah stop bringing it up I always
talk about Wuhan lably because it was so
obvious like Jon Stewart goes on yeah
whole Baron says it of course it happens
the only one more obvious than that was
Jesse Smollett because like but like of
course it didn't like you're telling me
it came from three feet outside of the
bio lab that studies the exact virus
that leads like crazy by Magic like it
just and if you were
if you were a doctor and you questioned
like the there was like there was no
other answer there was no other option
of course it was that like in the former
CDC director said that pressure was put
on him to not acknowledge that publicly
there was a uh scientific paper yeah
he's an conspiracy theorist I think it
was South China university in Beijing or
whatever it's called where they said
called if we did it no they post they
published yes
this is early on they said bats had bit
bitten people and urinated on people and
that's what they think caused the leak
and then they quickly retract this we
got rid of it because probably the CCP
came in and said do you enjoy living and
they're like we do it's like we've been
rid of it yeah of course well the guy
that you know that top scientist that
went missing that asked a question even
asked a question and you know and then
yeah obviously you saw this stuff in
Congressional testimony during Peak it
was like the fouchy emails versus the
fauci TV appearances you know on the
cover of like Vogue magazine or whatever
the hell he was doing like
they were literally a country like you
cannot so was he lying to the American
public or was he lying to his colleagues
in medicine because they were literally
Polar Opposites one of them has to be a
lie thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time